the stories of the Bible are some of the
most incredible tales in human
history tails of right and wrong good
versus evil but how did these stories
originate I'm curious to know where
these cultural ripples
began because regardless of your belief
they're important because they've shaped
the lives of billions over thousands of
years my name is Albert Lynn and I look
at the world in a unique way I use 21st
century technology to look back into the
past I explore the ancient world from
space with the help of science I'm going
to strip away the Earth to find answers
that have been hidden for
centuries I'll be traveling to some of
the most incredible and awe inspiring
places on
[Music]
Earth to reveal lost
cities and ancient
cataclysms
[Music]
and I'm going to start by unraveling the
mysteries of an iconic biblical tale
with a miracle at its
heart
let's start with the premise of the
story it describes a man named Moses who
demands Pharaoh free his people the
Israelites after years of
slavery according to the
story God unleashes a series of plagues
till finally Pharaoh agrees to release
the Israelites so they leave Egypt and
they head for the Promised Land
if we believe what is written in the
Bible then a satellite looking down on
Ancient Egypt some 3,000 years ago would
have seen something
amazing a fast Cavalcade of people the
Israelites heading for
freedom but Pharaoh changes his
mind and sends him his army to chase
them down and to kill
them the Israelites increased their
Pace but their way is blocked by an
impenetrable obstacle the Red
Sea they're
trapped and the Egyptian Army is closing
in
fast then supposedly something
extraordinary
happens Moses stretches out his
arm the waters
[Music]
part and the Israelites Escape across
the exposed
sea as the Egyptian Army pursues
them the waters flood
[Music]
backing
and Pharaoh's
[Music]
Army is
destroyed it's a great story but could
anything like this have ever really
happened in search of answers I've come
to the sight of all the action
the Beating Heart of the ancient
world just a few weeks ago I was driving
my kids to school and now I'm here in
Egypt on top of this
Monument there's just few places in the
world that make you feel like
uh
[Music]
overwhelmed
most experts agree that the story of
Moses and the Israelites happened in the
time of Ramsey
II the greatest of all
pharaohs he reached the height of his
powers around 1250
BC so that gives us a precise date
it's a start but there's a
problem the biblical texts tell us that
there were Israelites in Egypt for
Generations but no one has found any
physical trace of
them but I've been told there's one p
izing
clue to track it
down I'm off to one of the great museums
of the
[Music]
world
wow the answer I'm looking for well it
might just be hidden Within These
Walls it's like a warehouse of
Antiquities this place is
incredible
[Music]
I'm here to meet Meredith brand an
archaeologist working in
Cairo is there anything here that
describes the Israelites from the
Egyptian record there is something I'd
like to show you way over here in the
corner there's this Stila there's
something on the back that's really
interesting a v vital clue but hidden
deep in the
shadows if we look
here so this is the victory Stila of
marpa it's beautiful yeah it's
gorgeous that's marpa the guy in the
middle he's the son of Ramsey II the
ramsy the great the ramsy the great yeah
his son and he was ruling in the early
1200s
BC but what's really impressive is down
here this piece has actually been kind
of it looks discolored this is where
people have been touching it so much so
what you have the two re leaves right
there that's a y that long thing with
two lines with a rope that's an S that's
a mouth it's an r a single read is an I
then you have the vulture it's an A and
then you have another R the ancient
Egyptians didn't actually have an L in
their language so when they were writing
foreign words that had L's they used an
r and that would say Israel this
actually says Israel it actually says
Israel this is the first and the only
mentioning of the word Israel in an
ancient Egyptian text that's
remarkable from the Sun of ramsy II a
story written in stone describing his
victory over a people called
Israel but that's all there is the
Israelites are at the center of our
story but why is there only one mention
of Israel in the entire Egyptian
record maybe the problem is the
name what if the
Israelites were called something
else
[Music]
I'm following a lead heading south on a
near 500m Journey from Cairo to the city
of
[Music]
Luxor my whole life I never dreamed I'd
be watching the sunset over the
Nile it's
surreal
in the time of ramsy II Luxor was called
thieves it was his Capital
City the religious and ceremonial center
of the whole Egyptian
[Music]
Empire I'm
excited not just because we're
surrounded by all this
epic ancient history and
culture but because I've been told
there's evidence here of a mysterious
people who might just be the real
[Music]
Israelites Luxor is full of magnificent
temples and hidden secrets
and it might hold the key to my
quest you know I've been told about
these mysterious people the shasu and
the evidence surrounding them is really
compelling you know firstly there's
these hieroglyphs which read the shasu
of
Yahweh and Yahweh is the god of the
Israelites so maybe these are the people
I'm looking for
[Music]
for and secondly there's a
Papyrus that says the shasu fled Egypt
right around the same time as a story of
Moses was taking
place finally the reason I'm here among
all these Splendid temples I'm looking
for something much
smaller in the 1930s archaeologist found
something amazing
here the ruins of a very distinctive
house that many believe was built by the
shasu I want to find
it because remains of very similar
houses have been found all over the holy
lands if the shasu built houses in both
places that suggests their travels took
them between Egypt and the holy lands
just like the story of the
Israelites this is a photo of one of the
houses found in
Israel the layout makes it very
distinctive almost like a fingerprint so
this is what I'm looking
for somewhere in this Wasteland is where
the shasu might have lived
or rather under
it because on the surface all traces of
gone but it's not all
lost I can use my tech to see what my
eyes
can't stone walls underground have a
different Heat Signature to the
sand so by looking in the infared
Spectrum I can reveal Secrets hidden for
millennia
look at
that this structure looks
interesting it's a pretty good
match with the same signature
fingerprint as the house in
Israel wow we may have discovered
another shasu
house this is the first time in 3,000
years that anyone has seen it
it's
possible these are the Israelites that
I've been searching
for and there are traces of them
[Music]
everywhere
this might be the closest I can ever get
to
[Music]
them I just picked this up out of the
mud brick over there it's incredible you
know what really gets me about Pottery
is that this Amper which was made
thousands of years ago locked in time in
this clay as you run your fingers across
the
inside you're feeling the Fingerprints
of the person who made this
[Music]
powerful so I may have found the slaves
that Moses LED out of
Egypt now the question is can I find the
lost city where they began their
Journey according to the
Bible story of Exodus began at a city
called
ramsy you can't map that on your
phone archaeologists think ancient ramsy
was located 360 Mi north of Luxor on a
site now occupied by the town of
quan somewhere around here is a lost
city hard to believe looking at it now
all I can see is a Modern urban
sprawl so I'm looking for the city of
ramsy you're actually standing right in
it it's underneath our feet you kidding
me luckily my guide archaeologist henig
Fran has been exploring this site for 14
years and he knows that hidden amongst
the farmers Fields lies one in
incredible glimpse into a magnificent
past
wow what is this the feed of a massive
statue this is
surreal find this in the middle of a
field like
this are these glyphs this is actually
the heroglyph that are telling us who is
depicted in the Statue it's the name of
Ramy the
[Music]
second so this is a statue of his feet
that is his feet Yes I mean people are
just farming away around this ancient
statue of Ramsay
[Music]
huh we know there was a city called
ramsy here and 3,000 years
ago but what I want to know is that
what's under my
feet matches the descriptions in the
Bible and if it
does then maybe this is the starting
point for the events that inspired the
story of
Exodus I'm going to use technology to
peel back time and reveal the secrets of
this ancient
city Henning has used a technique here
called
magnetometry which records tiny changes
in the Earth's magnetic field to reveal
hidden structures Underground
I've got a hold of some magnetometry
data I've got a pretty cool idea of what
we can do with
it the statue in the field is right
here the magnetometry data shows it
belong to a
temple what else does the data reveal
and does it match what's described in
the
Bible for first the text describes ramsy
as a large and important
city Henning scans reveal that P ramsy's
covered 11 square
miles he estimates tens of thousands
lived here that's a huge City for
ancient
times this area was tightly packed with
houses where ordinary people
lived right next door this huge Villa
would have been home to someone rich and
Powerful next the texts describe ramsy
as a store City so there should have
been store
Rooms store rooms are usually
rectangular buildings divided into
narrow
Chambers looks like that's what we could
have
here finally we know that Pharaoh kept
his chariots
here that means Stables
[Music]
over here Henning's excavations have
uncovered a huge stable for
horses just what you would need for an
army of
Chariots so the answers are there laid
out in the
data but what I want to know now is what
this place looked
like that's where my tech comes
in
all right it's going to get pretty cool
now we built a augmented reality
platform that combines Henning's
magnetometry scans with a digital
reconstruction of what we think this
place might have looked like 3,000 years
ago and with this little piece of tech
we can get a window literally a window
into the past okay
ready archaeologists have helped us
recreate the city as it might have once
looked
[Music]
wow there it
is Ramsay's a
second see what's here looks like uh
this looks like it could have been a
store
[Music]
room look like a
stable
wow all right around the
corner a street of
houses and not too far to the
North look at that
[Music]
Palace
P ramsy must have been an incredible
place and maybe the shasu started their
Journey from
there and if they did where'd they go
was it the Red
Sea the really big question is how do
you explain what happened
next
one question has puzzled Scholars for
centuries if the Israelite story is
based on actual events what route did
they take to the holy
lands the direct route would have taken
them East along the Mediterranean
Coast but the biblical story Maps the
Israelites Journey via the desert road
towards the Red
[Music]
Sea and that means a long hike in this
searing
[Music]
heat I came
here just to understand this
desert what it might have been like to
try to cross
it maybe 3,000 years ago or today it's
all the same there's nothing here no
water it's not even a
tree kill me probably in a matter of
days according to the story somehow the
Israelites made it across straight into
an even tougher
challenge the Red Sea how on Earth were
they going to get across that that
before the Egyptians caught up with
them to find out I'm on my way to a
place where the biblical text say they
set up camp
Ethan now believed to be modern day is
[Music]
Mia all right nice yeah out of the sun
huh I'm here to meet biblical
archaeologist Professor Steven
so this is isia where we are yep it
turns out we're really close to the
description of where the Israelites
went it's at this point in the story
that the Bible tells the tale of Moses
parting the Red
Sea so from etham the Israelites would
have headed
south it makes sense that they would
have crossed the narrowest point of the
northern part of the Red Sea
[Music]
here to figure out the problem Moses
faced I need to know how wide and how
deep it was at this
point beet data can reveal the depth of
seas and oceans this is 300 ft about 90
m in depth and across it's 30 Mi right
that's a lot of water and to me that
doesn't make any
sense my calculations show that to
create a mile wide
Channel big enough to allow a vast group
of Israelites to
pass OES would have needed to move
nearly two trillion gallons of
water you need the Hoover Dam to hold
back that much
water
and even if it
happened how could so many people make
it over in just one
night let's say there was some event
that allowed the water to be removed for
a moment okay but even then how do you
make 30 Mi on foot in a single day I
mean for me I can't run 30 m in a day I
I agree with you that's a lot of
distance to
cover
right now The Parting of the Red Sea
looks
impossible at least it looks impossible
here but what if it happened somewhere
else Steven has come up with an
extraordinary theory that turns the
story on its
head the thing is that I don't think
this is the Red Sea that the Bible's
talking about I think it's important to
know that it was mistranslated we call
it the Red Sea because that's what we
read in our English Bible Red Sea but
the actual language in Hebrew was yam
souf and a better translation is sea of
reeds or the Reed sea Reed
sea that's
[Music]
incredible I
mean every story that I've heard about
this talks about the Red Sea The Parting
of the Red
Sea and I just learned that it could be
an misinterpretation of the Reed
sea I me that just blows my
mind I got to find out
[Music]
more I have no idea where to find the
mysterious Reed sea but I've been told
there's a clue hidden back in
[Music]
Luxor in a country filled with wonders
the carnic temple complex is one of the
greatest and engraved on one of its
magnificent walls is something
extraordinary an epic pictoral history
of the conquests of pharaoh CI
I father of ramsy
II an archaeologist Aiden Dodson
believes it could hold the key to my
quest what is this well basically what
you've got is a whole sequence here with
seti dealing with Rebels and he's
bringing them along to the border of
Egypt
who are those Rebels a bunch of people
know there's the shasu the shasu yes the
shasu bound as
captives and carved in stone the very
people I've been looking
for and
crucially it turns out that this
inscription is more than just a
story what you've got here is this
almost aerial view of the coast of Egypt
and then we've got this water course
coming through so this is actually a map
effectively yeah it's very schematic
one and Aiden believes it's a map that
could show us the way to the Reed
seene well this is a river is there an
image of a reed sea well basically
you've got this Waterway here the little
things on either side are actually Reeds
it fits quite nicely being of the Nile
Delta which is a fairly marshy kind of
area
may look like a river but Aiden thinks
this channel represents the whole Nile
Delta with all its Lakes tributaries and
even
crocodiles there's one more clue in the
biblical text it says the night before
they crossed the Reed sea the Israelites
camped near a place called
migdol migdol is a generic term for a
fortress it doesn't actually mean a
specific
place however in the context of what
you're trying to look into we've
actually got one of these Mig dolls just
here I am incredibly excited about this
fact that we're starting to get closer
to the unfolding of a potential
story and it's in a
map but where is
mingle and how does it relate to the
Reed sea the ancient Egyptians Drew
their Maps up upside down with the south
at the top to make sense of it I need to
look at it in a different
way and it all becomes clear mdol is
east of the Nile
Delta the Israelites Journey now takes a
very different
route if we follow this map the strange
detour South to the Red Sea is
gone instead from Ethan they turn north
towards migdol then East on a direct
route to the holy
lands I'm going to follow this route
towards
mcville and try to find the Reed
seat straight away something on the map
catches my eye a large body of water
called Lake manzala in the heart of the
Nile
Delta
[Music]
and it's full of
reads this is it Lake
manzala and it's massive I mean it it's
it's
huge if you were being chased by an
army there's no way around it you'd
think it was a sea and there's reads
everywhere be a reed
SE it's possible it really
is what I discovered next took my breath
away I'm reading this account from
1882 from a British army officer Major
General Sir Alexander Bruce
tulk tulk and his men were camped near
Lake manzala when he witnessed something
truly
extraordinary this is what he
wrote a gale of wind from the Eastward
set
in and became so strong that I had to
cease
[Music]
work
the next morning on going
out I found that Lake manzala had
totally
disappeared the effect of the high wind
on the shallow water having actually
driven it away Beyond the
Horizon the natives were walking about
in the mud where the day before the
fishing boats now a ground had been
floating it suddenly flashed across my
mind that that I was witnessing a
similar event to what had taken place at
the time of the passage of the so-called
Red Sea by the
Israelites
wow maybe the same thing happened here
all those thousands of years
ago I've come to an ocean Lagoon called
Lake
manzala
I want to find out from atmospheric
scientist Carl
Drews if science can explain what tulk
saw here in
1882 so this is Lake manzala yes this is
a huge Coastal Lagoon this is about
maybe waste deep right offshore if you
get farther out it's maybe chest deep
and farther out maybe even over your
head so it's a real Shallow
Lake Carl is convinced that what tulk
saw is scientifically possible and that
he was right to think that it was caused
by strong
winds if you had wind blowing at 50 mph
for 6 hours you get all the water
shifting about 6 miles um that's called
wind set down okay so that would
basically create this effect of removing
the ocean yeah it'll just peel away from
the shore so the ocean is gone the sea
is gone and there's dry land there and
when the wind stops the water comes
rushing back again that is the best
explanation for the phenomenon that's
reported in Exodus
14 this is footage of a beach in the
Bahamas it was taken just weeks before
hurricane Irma hit in
2017 now look at the same Coastline in
the immediate
aftermath the water's gone and the land
it's exposed The Parting of this sea
isn't a miracle in
[Music]
science but there still is a
problem lake monzal is over here but
migdall where the story says the
Israelites camped before they crossed
it's here 30 Mi away and nowhere near a
lake lake bzal is in the wrong
place but this is a mystery I think I
can solve from space
satellites can track how Rivers move and
change course over
time since the time of Moses the lakes
and channels of the Nile Delta will have
moved many
miles this is what the area around
migdall looks like
now if we switch to the infrared part of
the spectrum we can reveal areas that
were once
underwater so let's jump back in
time and see what it might have looked
like in 1250
BC and there it
is that's very nice it's really neat to
see all this
stuff a read SE exactly where it's
described
in the
story and there's more Carl thinks the
shape of this ancient Lake matches the
story
perfectly so they're marching along this
Ridge here and they get stuck right
there and then when the water shifted
this way and parted around that point
they ran across to there potentially
this this is what you think could happen
that's my that's my suggestion
yes so finally maybe this explains the
mystery of The Parting of the Red
Sea but for me the theory misses one
major point of the story which is that
water supposedly rushed back in drowning
the Army and killing everybody there
these Waters they're really shallow
probably no more than 6 ft
deep it doesn't add
up just doesn't quite do it
perhaps like many ancient Tales The
Exodus story was formed from memories of
more than one
event it could have even been from
different
times so I'm on the hunt for a more
violent
ending and there's a clue back down
south
in one of the most important sites in
the ancient
world this is the Valley of the Kings
where Egypt's great Pharaohs were buried
you know to in
common even Ramsay's a
second but I'm not here for
[Music]
them
this is the tomb of
thutmosis there's stars all over the
ceiling this is what I came to see
[Music]
I heard about
these drowning
Egyptians just like Pharaoh's
Army but what makes this painting really
significant is the
date who was created around 1550
BC 300 years before or the story of
Exodus but right at the time of an
ancient disaster so jaw-dropping that
people would talk about it for thousands
of
[Music]
years it turns out the final part of my
quest lies not in Egypt but 500 mil
Northwest in the middle of the
Mediterranean
[Music]
in the ancient world the island of
sanini was a vast volcano called
Thea in around 1550 BC the same time as
the painting of the drowned
Egyptians it erupted with a force of 2
million atomic
bombs hurling billions of tons of rock
and Ash 20 M into the air it was one of
the biggest volcanic eruptions in human
history but could it have inspired the
story of Pharaoh's drowned
Army Dr I namu is a scientist who has
studied the eruption and the effect it
had on the region we had a lot of
parastic flows that enter into the sea
very very violently with high speed what
do you mean
parastic you have a lot of materials
like pamis volcanic rocks this is pomis
yeah this is
pomis all of this material fallen into
the sea very violently creating these
waves of energy boom boom yeah generated
multiple meat
tsunamis not only one
that's like
[Music]
unbelievable but were any of these
tsunamis so big that they could have
traveled 500 miles to
Egypt I can combine E's data with a
satellite
image to see just how much material hit
the
water these underwater mountains are all
p parastic material from the
eruption Eevee calculates that the total
volume of 19 cubic miles of pyroclastic
material entered the
water that's nearly 3 trillion cubic
feet hitting the sea at hundreds of
miles an
hour scientists believe this eruption
would have caused a series of
tsunamis the biggest could have been 100
ft
high this monster wave could still have
been 20 ft when it hit the coast of
Egypt we know from recent events just
how destructive tsunamis can
be the coast of Egypt is flat and
low-lying the wave could have traveled
miles inward the effects they would have
been
devastating it's incredible that a
volcanic island in the Mediterranean
could be the last piece of an ancient
Egyptian
[Music]
puzzle in that time anyone witnessing a
Sunami would think it was an act of God
and if you were fleeing persecutions and
the Seas parted for any reason you would
think an higher force was helping you
you add in a mighty leader with a staff
no matter what you believe you get a
story so resonant that it's lasted for
thousands of years it's inspired
multiple
religions and it shaped the lives of
[Music]
billions